Virginia's political chaos is
intensifying with Governor Ralph Northam
showing no sign that he will step down
the Democrat elected in 2017 is under
fire over a racist photo printed under
his name in a 1984 yearbook the governor
met with his cabinet yesterday part of a
strategy to manage the crisis day by day
but the Lieutenant Governor who would
replace Northam now faces a claim of
sexual assault from more than a decade
ago claim that has not been
substantiated at O'Keefe is outside the
governor's mansion in Richmond heed good
morning good morning a source familiar
with a cabinet meeting held by governor
Northam says that it was emotional but
that not one member of the cabinet
called for his resignation
if Northam goes he would be replaced by
lieutenant governor Justin Fairfax he
says an allegation that he sexually
assaulted a woman at the 2004 Democratic
National Convention in Boston is not
true it's all completely political it's
a complete smear Virginia lieutenant
governor Justin Fairfax strongly denied
the allegation of sexual assault late
Monday saying the accusation is
resurfacing now as he's on the verge of
becoming governor I think it's obvious
what it is it's obvious that it's a
smear it's obvious that we're on the eve
of a pretty historic time and you know
and there are people who for whatever
reason may want to come out the story
published by the same conservative
website that released the racist photo
from Virginia Governor Ralph Northam see
yearbook page deepened the political
crisis at the State Capitol protestors
outside the governor's mansion demanded
that Northam stepped down while the
governor remained holed up in private
meetings he's hurting Virginians he's
hurting African Americans and calls for
Northam shreds Ignatian are still coming
from fellow Democrats I just lost the
confidence of enough people that I think
the right thing to do is step down and
national Republicans the president has
said he thinks it's unforgivable it's
unconscionable Kirk Cox is the Virginia
House Speaker what if anything could you
and your colleagues do at this point to
force him out if he refuses to go I'll
be suing impeachment that's a very high
standard
and so I think that's why we have called
for the resignation we hope that's what
the governor does Fairfax has not called
on Northam to step down but notably the
two have not spoken since before that
awkward news conference back on Saturday
a spokeswoman for the governor says it's
absolutely untrue that their team was
the one that leaked word of the
allegation of assault against Fairfax an
Eastern Virginia Medical School the
school where that yearbook photo of the
governor came from says it's holding a
news conference later today to discuss
unacceptable photos in those yearbooks
bianna all right we'll continue to say
on this story ad thank you